hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until done tonight I
was on TV I was on the Jimmy Kimmel show
how cool is that I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to get any footage from it
but I was indeed on the Jimmy Kimmel
show tonight talking to him about the
soul of what Let's Plays are all about
but not enough about that time to get
back to this game so there's something
new here hang on Sam hit the psycho to
escape good I'm glad I beat that douche
in his face but it didn't do me a lot of
good see escape the threat unscathed
good on the same page Matt supported
Emily's plan to go to the tower and get
help good I thought it was Matt's idea
originally but I'm gonna okay whatever
all right let's go now I'm playing Emily
at the tower probably good
goodbye birdie I know some other spooks
are gonna be waiting for me me to remind
people let's get that radio working
first what kind of weird awkward dialog
was that it didn't even make sense what
you were saying
anyway need I remind people in some
mildly threatening way that uh I can
barely hear myself talk this game
oh my god lol it's just a security light
motion sensor probably someone was
breathing a little bit heavily we got
his totem over here this is gonna be a
death one gray I forget what gray means
was a yo yellow sorry were you playing
Russian roulette with a normal
nine-millimeter
that's not a good thing in fact it's
pretty stupid
okay whatever we all this tower is this
where Emily explodes into flames and
somehow dies I mean I know how
everyone's been saying that I've been
getting everyone killed but hey I don't
think anyone's dead yet I don't even
think that josh is dead I think that was
a big fake conspiracy that he's actually
the psycho and he did this because he
went bonkers after his sister's died
that's what I think happened
I'm pretty sure anyway I have no idea to
back that up with any sort of evidence
but thankfully the game is that Ben's
world for me just yet
this is dark and spooky and Mysterio pee
what could goopy happen all right I'm
going up I guess
come along Matt Deary love of my life
for now anyway Mike used to be that but
I've moved on I've chosen to be a 4.0
student and a giant meanie puss okay
well it's well it doesn't look good oh
come on man why you got do that wait
wait where am I
Oh oh I'm over here well damn it why did
Matt leave that behind seems like
something you could have been very
useful to a psycho that's gonna follow
us up here I guess the Saiga was kind of
busy with Sam but now the Sam has been
caught once again I don't
are we I don't know about that
if we add an accent sure would be easier
to defend ourselves all right fine here
we go come on up I don't know if there's
any other choices to be made on the way
up here but for now I'll just enjoy what
I got Tony when I was on the Jimmy
Kimmel show yeah he was very well oh let
me just feel this out here I am the
watch whisperer I probably very much so
I'm being dumb you can't stop me from
being dumb
it's my natural state of being all right
way yeah it was the last-minute thing
who called me like two days ago they
told me that they want to be on board so
I did it very quick turnaround they work
fast those professionals but accountancy
amateurs like me it's not as quick and
not as well made okey-dokey
okay all right now that we're alone
we've got some time to ourselves I'm so
tired from that climb I told okay fine
I'm sorry I'm sorry I don't mean to be
annoying hello hi yeah yeah no joke
and maybe not in so much a disappearance
is a horrible horrible accidents all
right let me investigate everything
before I get the radio there no power oh
I don't know what's happening there
might be no power however we'll wait for
it
yeah it's gotta be just that simple I
know how all these high school students
ever solve this mystery maybe through
this door that's conveniently right here
anybody home anybody wanna dance
oh is this a little bit of oh maybe it's
not the food's back but then again maybe
it is and I should just hurry up oh god
or my fingers broken too I broke a nail
cam flowers very sorry sir
[Music]
yeah go team go
we're the best we're so in love and just
because we say that out loud doesn't
mean there's any problems going on
really all right love horrible horrible
love oh hello
looks useful good thing I found that
food be the one to do the thing I'm
gonna keep it it's it it's a pretty
flare gun really pretty
what shoot it no Stuart we don't need it
just yet
of course geez why would you why would
you shoot it well that's exactly what I
did in the forest though but I mean why
would I do that
that's so stupid I want to do it now I
want to shoot it go into the sky cuz
amidst all the resource hey don't
question me I'm dumb now I really want
to shoot it damn it come on now oh come
on I want to shoot it now I really won't
shoot it fine what is this
yeah so what did it printout oh sorry
slowly or quickly I'm not controlling
that
okay we're gonna be like this Olli and
calmly and before the demons that are
below comply comply calmly no yell at
them
[Music]
we're gonna die we're gonna die we're
gonna die probably didn't matter it
whichever way we go if they can a mother
[Music]
guess you just
was I supposed to do something there let
it make it a sense where they all happen
to do right how they end up in mines
don't seem good hey what's supportive
suspicious this is the right time to be
like this hey wait a second you gotta
think about this go the wrong path I
could probably do Emily but why would I
do that it'd be such a doozie thing to
do at this moment other why am i tempted
to do it ah god I wanna accuse her of so
many things
oh man okay fine fine god I'll help her
ah fine let me work this out okay this
is any better thank you okay whoa
whatever you say I want you so badly oh
I want to be a sarcastic douche right
now oh you'll be the perfect opportunity
I'm crying to the heavens why can't I be
a dude oh I wanted me to do so badly ah
okay all right fine I'll be I'll be
normal sorry I got I'd just have to get
it all out of my system I had to get it
all out no don't move No Oh No I'll get
you no I'll save you
yeah what save Emily ogre save Emily
Oh give me that kind of yell dinner and
then save Emily die together or don't go
home at all
wait
that results in both dying
[Music]
oh man I could damn it it's one of those
things that didn't matter what I did
isn't it so wouldn't it matter to find a
been a giant prick it's how are you
saying I got the good butterflies it's
gotta be away huh it's gotta be some
right god damn it I hate that
wait is this something I heard screams
cry not good damn it high five there was
gonna be way oh man I thought
[Music]
what the hell happened and that wouldn't
have killed you probably not what the
hell happened why did that happen what
the hell is that no no you can't just no
you can't just pull that [ __ ] with
me and then just say it's totally normal
hey I buzz in a sarcastic douche I've
once it
I was very compassionate and now that I
should've pew pew the goddamn flare I
should have been a sarcastic douche
fighter what is that I woulda done it in
the first place
[Applause]
I know Ashley just stop okay I don't
want to think about what just happened
we're finding Sam uh-huh
yeah okay I still don't know why that
happened why would that just somethin
happen I'm totally caught off guard
about that that's a bunch of full up
I've got bigger problems to worry about
maybe this is what everyone was talking
about when they said I was killing
everybody oh this is where my actions
have gone wrong oh well whatever why is
there a ghost in this place why is there
ghosty goos I don't like a room full of
ghosts he goes hi that's where the
spirit realm gets in okay just gonna
wait a minute did you just see that did
I see what that what that was that I'm
serious why don't you believe me I said
I saw it doesn't that count for anything
held okay
your mind is fried my mind is fried I
don't even trust what I've been seeing
insist no I saw a ghost I saw it too
yeah I'm sure
yeah that's right I wish we could just
go find everyone else and what if Sam
needs us what if she's in trouble
Oh God
oh cool yeah let's go down the door that
just mysteriously open for no reason
great good idea we're all having fun
here okay I'm coming along
lover of mine I guess don't mind the
blood I'm covered in that weird I read
it all oh that's exactly what I was
hoping for
mmm yes I'm still like reeling from what
the hell just happened in last seen
how's this a bunch of bull bunch of ball
man I was doing so good no one was dead
no damn nope - were dead such baloney
[Music]
I'm not imagining things I saw what
happened to Josh the shed worried about
you know what I'm really worried about
okay I'm worried about Sam what's
happened to her there's some maniac out
here that she could be dead - don't say
that please
Chris wait Chris Chris Chris Meers nikto
what do you see it no you weren't
looking at your phone ooh dip what are
you tweeting hashtag there's a freaking
ghost yes she did
there is no ghost here the ghost of what
your freaked out because of what
happened with Josh I'm paying attention
I saw it I saw it goes and it looks like
what do you think they followed us up
here from the Seahawks they did it
because ghosts don't exist okay okay I
was talking to us at the seance Chris I
don't know
there's an awfully elaborate spook fest
if it is just all fakery but I don't
know that it is because I'm not sure any
of this is real based on what that
dududu was saying this all could be
fakery no all of it every single of it
yeah every little bit of it every single
bit of it oh she walked in nowhere good
glad there's no goo Goo's around
okay I got a key oh my god yeah so run
towards it it's showing us the way to
our death let's march towards it cuz
well it's mom
all right come on man scheme is so weird
why would she walk - oh god it's like
it's not like anything that's us hiding
there waiting for Hannah
last year but it's it's so accurate I
mean that's exactly where I was thinking
that's where Matt was was set up by
someone who was there or someone or
something that was watching us maybe
it's a warning
I think someone I think someone put this
here to mess with them no it has to be
the ghost is trying to tell us the
maniac killed Hannah bad I think it's
this bastard that he's easier trying to
[ __ ] with our heads why would he set
this all up Chris
she's trying to tell us that he's gonna
come after us all we could run away at
any time okay hmm this from years ago
let's read it
oh why not me I'm finally agreed the
invitations are out the party's gonna
happen I hate having to wait so for
admins and said Lily had nothing for
Mike to make oMG my confirmed he phoned
Josh this afternoon party time let's
keep reading then keep reading
oh I want more come on keep uh-huh fine
whatever
there's some bizarre ghostery happen
here does that horse have no eyes I
think it has no eyes this is a little
weird
I will admit there's like three
different types of monsters going on
here there's a psycho murderer there's a
monster and then there's ghosts ghosts
Lee goes yes bring it on [ __ ]
sir madam lovely persons what the hell
why would he just sprint into it
idiots gleam I thought that said Queen
[Music]
lost so random okay how is this helpful
for a projector of some sorts to protect
some ghost seekers yes Oh excellent
excellent indeed hey I found a schizos I
put it in my butt pocket alright so
how's it gonna help me defend from girls
to use because if they're all ghosts I
found a secret oh my god
I totally did oh my god what the hell oh
definitely some secrets yet going on
here makes sense I guess I don't like
being watched
uh-huh
[Music]
okay how's it getting signal to anywhere
how would anyone be able to watch what
it was going on - I doubt there's Wi-Fi
[Music]
thanks for the color commentary Chris
really appreciate it was that the sound
of the tower falling and the the douchey
death that befallen Matt and Emily
yeah this looks like the place where Sam
ran down aisle of the whispering I love
the clattering of the Damned
thanks for waiting for me Chris douche I
don't blame you I wanted to do was
forget last year ever happened to be
honest not sure we hadn't thought she
was doing yeah well you know how it is
when you're crushing pretty hard on
somebody oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait she did overreact
but let's be some sympathetic here if it
was you don't you think you would have
run away
I mean who likes being made fun of
people don't make fun of me to your face
what Chris we made her look so stupid
in front of all of her friends and the
guy she liked I can't imagine doing
anything worse to somebody yep okay we
got a stand it's empty
but I don't know if anything else
happened why are you swimming in on the
butt
where are you zooming in on her but why
is that necessary hello this is another
the heck was that bracelet she was naked
she was completely Bunker and naked fast
whatever all right there's got to be
something that's about to happen here
it's gotta be something that's about to
happen I know there will be hello
he'll fake new paper newspapers what
doesn't make any sense wait it wouldn't
make sense if like say a Josh Thai
person was trying to boggle up
everything going on here that would make
very good sense to me I don't blame you
okay I'm really freaked out too but if
Sam's down there all alone with a maniac
we're basically killing ourselves got a
good point there I'm really scared
well I mean that would be the truth
really scared it's true but no I'm
ballsy as hell I'm a woman I'm strong
yes see gotta be good friends gotta be
the best of friends I'm wondering if
there was any way to avoid Sam being
captured but then again I don't know how
deep the choices run in this game
speaking of which I am probably going to
end this episode right
don't look at me that way here okay
how's my updates going I'm so honest and
charitable and brave not very romantic
though why did I hurt oh oh me and Chris
we're getting along quite well I don't
know why it's red though that that makes
it look bad I have no idea what that is
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I will continue this very soon
and as always I will see you in the next
video thanks
[Music]